sein jüngstes buch hat 1724 seiten 18
jahre lang hat der ungarische
schriftsteller péter nádas daran
geschrieben
parallel geschichten heißt das werk und
wie in seinem werk sonst auch erkundet
nádas darin die weiten und abgründe
menschlicher existenz und die geschichte
europas im zwanzigsten jahrhundert
er selber ist jude überlebender des
holocaust zeuge der kommunistischen
diktatur
na das hat er lebt worüber er schreibt
und na das ist der philosoph unter den
schriftstellern zudem fotograf im
gespräch mit norbert bischofberger
gewährt er einblick in sein schreib
universum sein fotografisches werk und
in seine philosophie
johanna dass sie sind schriftsteller und
fotograf was war jetzt eigentlich am
anfang das wort oder das bild es ist
immer das bild also es kommt immer das
bild zuerst und dann das wort wir haben
diese fähigkeit das ist in allen also es
gibt keine ausnahme wir fassen mit dem
blickt die welt auf und dann machten
daraus wörter machen und daraus das wort
auch bei mir ist das so aber wenn sie
fragen welche wo meine interesse liegt
dann würde ich sagen dass ich habe mit
mit mit mit dem schreiben angefangen als
ich elf jahre alt war habe ich mit dem
schreiben angefangen und seitdem blieb
es dabei
und dann später ist das bild oder diese
kindliche dazugekommen durch
verschiedene zufälle die ich überhaupt
nicht bedacht hätte
wenn diese ausstellung jetzt in zug
nicht dazu käme wie sie es in ihrer
kindheit vander hat bilder wenn sie an
die erinnerung denken zuerst oder sind
das sätze oder wörter natürlich
sinnbilder ihn zuerst bilder aus dem
krieg die sind meine erste
erinnerungsbilder und ich habe später in
der pubertät geprüft ob diese bilder
fantasie bier sind oder richtige bilder
aber die sind richtige bilder
merkwürdige weise aus meinem zweiten
lebensjahr und aus dem zweiten
lebensjahr hat man sehr selten bildern
das ist sehr früher ja die sind
dramatische bilder eines krieges eine
richtige ja ein proben bomben angegeben
das ist meine meinung
sie eröffnen jetzt gerade mit diesem
tragischen ereignis sie sehen vor kurzem
70 jahre alt geworden also 1942 mitten
im krieg in eine jüdische familie
hineingeboren wie haben sie denn
überhaupt überlebt in budapest
angesichts der judenverfolgung und des
holocaust
meine eltern gehörten zu den wenigen die
die diese schweinereien nicht
akzeptierten also die die gesetze nicht
akzeptierten
die sind in die legalität gegangen sie
waren kommunisten die waren überzeugte
kommunisten gehörten zu
widerstandsbewegung und ich habe falsche
papiere eine fahrt der name gehabt hiess
kovac also schmidt eine gewöhnliche name
aber peter wurde beibehalten
ich kenne ich sehe also es ist noch da
meine falsche geburtshaus weiß
geburtsurkunde und mein vater war mit 22
freunde und mit seiner seine
bruder in einen keller eingemauert woher
falsche papiere gerade falsche papiere
und flugblätter gemacht hat meine mutter
und die tante hat die aufgabe gehabt
gewisse daten hin zu bringen und die
neue papiere und flugblätter zu holen
und zu verteilen an verschiedene
verbindungen legale verbindungen
das war natürlich überaus riskant dass
er auch deswegen sehr riskant ich traue
nicht einmal hinein zu denken wie
riskant das war weil meine mutter hat
auch außer mir noch mehrere kinder durch
die durch diese krieg und und belagerung
von butt budapest durchgebracht und wenn
die verhaftet worden wären dann wäre es
wirklich eine katastrophe gewesen mein
vater war mehrmals verhaftet nicht zu
dieser zeit sondern früher aber meine
mutter nie sie war eine ja eine
ziemliche ziemlich mutige person
sie beschreiben dass sie in diesem alter
ersten ihre bücher mit dem titel die
bibel
da legt sie eine bibel auf diese
flugblätter jedenfalls die frau die da
drinnen beschrieben ist und ich jetzt
eben an dieser stelle erinnert die sie
jetzt geben von ihrer mutter ja ja das
ist was da so dass es nicht selbst
biografisch das ist eine geschichte
aber diese motiv stimmt konto zu es
stimmt wir haben das erste längere werk
ende eines familienromans erzählt die
geschichte eines knaben der bei seinen
großeltern aufwuchs
ihre eltern sind früh gestorben sie sind
bei ihren großeltern aufgewachsen nein
nein nicht mal meinen großeltern
aufgewachsen als jugendlicher meine in
ein
nicht also das ist auch eine eine
fiktion
meine eltern sind früh gestorben aber
ich bin bei meiner tante aufgewachsen so
zu sagen aber ich war schon in der
pubertät und mit sehr großer erziehung
und es ging nicht um erziehung das ist
das war eher ein nein konflikte aber
eine geistige ein sehr wichtiger
geistige verhältnis mit meiner tante und
diesen großvater der in diesem ende
eines familienromans ebendieses
abendländische jüdische erbe weiter gibt
den gab es nein nein nein das ist auch
fiktion
mein großvater war ein wunderbare person
aber von ganz anderen schlag
er war schweigsam nicht so gesprächig
wände eines familienromans unglaublich
schweigsam aber mit seinem
schweigsamkeit hatte die dinge so zu
sagen sehr stark gelenkt und auch mich
gelenkt und einige sehr starke hinweise
wie man sich verhält gegeben
[Musik]
besonders darin wie man zwischen lüge
und wahrheit unterscheidet und er war
kein lügner
und er hat lüge nicht zugelassen auch
nicht wenn es vielleicht auch zug allzu
gewagt gewesen ist
er hat das nicht zugelassen aber keine
rüge erteilt seine stimme nie gehoben
und ist von meinen augen gestreut
ja gehen wir zum großvater sowie ihr
hier drin lebt in ende eines
familienromans dass wir vielleicht mal
einen ausschnitt hören aus einem ihrer
werke
er sagt zu dem knaben deine beobachtung
ist richtig und genauer beobachtung ist
die grundlage jeder erkenntnis aber wir
müssen uns bemühen unsere beobachtungen
in ein system zu bringen
in meiner jugend habe ich viel hegel
gelesen das war familientradition bei
uns mein großvater den urgroßvater ließ
sich die bücher direkt aus berlin und
aus wien schicken und gleich er nur ein
gastwirt war aber alles was auf der welt
existiert ist lebendig die welt muss man
sich vorstellen als das riesige
lebewesen und auch das haus wie alles
andere wird geboren und stirbt und das
ist das leben
ja das leben zu verkörpern oder die welt
verkörpern das ist eine alte
philosophische trick oder einen gedanke
oder eine idee
ob das richtig ist oder nicht das weiß
ich nicht ich glaube dass die das leben
ist etwas viel strikter viel einfacher
wir können das nicht durch einen person
lebendig machen und dadurch ist die die
welt oder das universum bleibt draußen
bleibt ruhig
in seinen gesetzen und diese gesetze
sind sozusagen eine art widerspiegelung
unserer gesetze bzw
unsere widerspiegelt diese gesetze also
es gibt einen zusammenhang aber keine
verkörperung hier geht es ja um genaues
beobachten erkenntnis haben gesagt von
ihrem großvater und sie eben die
wahrheit nicht dass lügen gelernt von
wem haben sie diese unglaubliche
beobachtungsgabe diese gabe zu schildern
die menschen in
werken in einen sog des erzählens
hineinzuziehen
ich brauche das nicht zu lernen niemand
braucht das zu lernen alle dass es meine
tiefste überzeugung dass wir alle diese
fähigkeit haben um wir chinesen sind
oder schweizer oder ungar oder juden
oder das ist egal wir haben die das
gleiche beobachtungsgabe
das ist schon eine frage was sich mit
den beobachtungen oder was ich mit
meiner eine reine wahrnehmungen gemacht
das ist der erste phase wahrzunehmen und
dann die wahrnehmen wahrgenommene zu
speichern
wie ich das speichere das hängt von sehr
vielen faktoren ab von soziales also wie
ich erzogen bin in welche familie ist
geboren sind und geboren bin in welchem
land ich geboren bin ob dieses land
ästhetisch eingestellt ist oder ihre er
oder kultur kulturkreis oder eher
unästhetisch die rationelle pragmatisch
also das hängt schon sehr viele von sehr
vielen faktoren ab aber diese urbild hat
jeder und davon wie das ausgegangen
dann dann wird es in verschiedenen
stellen in dem gehirn gespeichert wird
es das als emotion gespeichert wir das
auch als geist gespeichert also wird
bewertet und diese bewertung oder
endergebnisse der bewertungen werden
gespeichert und all das gibt einem die
wahrnehmungsfähigkeit einer menschen ab
aber alle nehmen
auf gleicher weise war alles wie die
tiere auch wenn also dass es nicht nicht
eine besondere fähigkeit des menschen
die tiere partner und und nehmen alles
war was nötig ist sie haben von diesem
fundus berichtet heben den die menschen
haben
ein fundus ist die kindheit in ihrer
kindheit in ihrer jugend ist ihre mutter
früh gestorben 1953 dann drei jahre
später hat sich ihr vater 1956 im jahr
des ungarischen volksaufstand dass das
leben genommen
sie haben es erwähnt ihre eltern waren
im kommunistischen widerstand dann in
der kommunistischen partei ihr vater ein
hoher funktionär wird sich seine rolle
auf die familie ausgewirkt er war nicht
so hohe funktionär er war ein ziemlich
mittelmäßige funktionär und auch meine
mutter war eine mittelmäßige funktionär
diese partei sie haben sehr viel vor dem
kriege und nachdem in dem krieg
geleistet aber sie kunden keine richtige
partei karriere machen das war
vielleicht mein glück diese karriere hat
direkt nach der machtübernahme von
kommunisten ein rückschlag erlitten
meine mutter war eine ungeduldige person
und sie hat ständig den anweisungen
meines großvaters gefolgt und sagte was
er meint was sie meinte und dadurch war
diese karriere zu ende ziemlich tragisch
zu ende und ich habe davon sehr viel
gelernt ich habe meine rückschlüsse
gezogen nämlich und das war bis zur
wende ein problem für die für die
wohlmeinende leute ob die schrecknisse
und fehler dieses system systembedingt
sind oder nicht ob sie von menschlichen
zufälligkeiten abhängen
aber da die waren systembedingt und ich
habe das schon in meiner kindheit
gelernt also in dieser richtung war ich
nicht mehr zu verleiten ich habe mich
sehr früh von die kommunistische
bewegung distanziert und und auch zum
teil meiner familie den rücken gekehrt
und auf meine eigene füße gestellt
sie waren als junger mensch fotoreporter
als journalist tätig wir haben ein bild
das sie mit 18 jahren ein selbstbildnis
zeigt eine fotografie sie haben ja
später unter dieser zensur also in
dieser zeit selber gelitten
sie schreiben oder beschreiben immer
wieder dass sie eben den beruf letztlich
deswegen aufgeben mussten war für sie
ihr vater ein verräter nein ich war
ein verräter ich war ein verräter und
ich wusste darüber nicht
also ich habe meinen also diese familien
teil weil meine familie bestand aus
proletarier bestand aus bürgerlichen ich
habe nicht die proletarier nicht die
bürgerliche verraten ich habe eigentlich
meine meine eltern verraten
beziehungsweise ich habe meine eltern
nicht gefolgt in der sicht der eltern ja
und ich habe durch verraten aber mein
vater war kein fehler hat er mein vater
war ein regelrechter opfer sich selbst
also er hat sich selbst geopfert und er
wusste nicht wofür er sich umfeld er war
angeklagt mit einer sache was richtig
nicht begangen hat und konnte sich nicht
reinwaschen bei seiner genossen und zwei
tage vor seinem selbstmord hatte ein
endlich ein beschluss bekommt wo er als
schuldlos an angewiesen war
aber das war ihm schon zu spät sind und
er ist selbst begangen er wollte auch
uns kinder
ich habe eine irgendwie bruder
mitbringen im tod und aus seinen
abschiedsbrief geht hervor dass das in
letzten minute vor dem bett meines
bruders der war ein sehr schönes gehen
doch nicht vollzogen
konnte und dann hatte einer einige
zeilen uns geschrieben
wie haben sie das aufgenommen wie sie
das später gehört haben
nein ich habe den brief gefunden ich
habe diese abschiedsbrief gefunden
ja das hat mich natürlich erschüttert
das war schon ein schock dass man ein
leben lang trägt deswegen war mir ich
spielte in meinem leben sehr lange zeit
mit dem selbstmord und aber diese wege
war mehr verstellt weil ich nicht diese
schock weitergeben wollte niemanden und
besonders nicht denen dich liebhabe also
mir ist dieser weg verstellt worden
durch meinen vater
das war auch eine sehr schwere aber eine
große leere
warum macht man das nicht und warum
leben die religionen dass man nicht
machen darf ja doch die selbst modell
selbstmörder selbst erleben dass wie wie
das berichtet wird als negatives die die
das nicht selbst machen also nicht
selbst wörter sind erleben den tod als
etwas positives das habe ich auch getan
es gibt eine andere geschichte die mich
sehr umtreibt in der ausstellung im zuge
der aktuellen die sie über ihre
fotografischen werke vor allem selber
kuratiert haben gibt es ein bild von
anderes sogar von seiner frau hat das
sogar ist eine ungarische fotograf in
sie hat sich am 22
dezember 1943 also mitten im krieg das
leben genommen in ihrer wohnung in
budapest dazu vor alle ihre fotos und
alle ihre negative verdammt ja diese
aktfotografie von ihr hat ihr mann
anderer shooter gemacht
er ist ein jahr später auf dem weg bei
der jüdisch nach auschwitz umgekommen
ja sie haben überlebt sie haben jetzt
noch mal in einer großen offenheit
drastisch geschildert dass sie noch mal
überlebt haben
fühlen sie sich in ihrem werk in ihrem
leben solchen menschen wie katar sogar
verpflichtet ja eindeutig ich habe eine
kleine hommage ihr gemacht wo ich diese
lebensgeschichte erzählen sie hat ihre
negative und ihre bilder verbrannte in
ihrem leben com erschien sind also das
war eines großer schatzkammer 30 jahren
ja einige sind geblieben die hier auch
in zug ausgestellt sind einige sind eine
gebilde sind geblieben und einige
negative sind geblieben weil sie hat
keine eigene dunkelkammer gehabt sie kam
aus einer sehr wohlhabende aus einer
reichen familie alles wurde weggenommen
nach drei juden gesetzen hat besaß sie
nicht ihre katze eine kleine katze sagt
man also es kann sein dass sie wirklich
eine kleine katze gehabt hatte
ihre kleine katze warf und dem
hausmeister gefüttert weil sie hat
wirklich nichts zu essen und sie war
allzu stolz etwas abzunehmen und dann
ist sie selbst mal begangen aber diese
negative einige negative und positive
ist bei einem in der dunkelkammer wo sie
arbeitete beim freundin gottseidank
geblieben und sie ist einer der
wichtigste person im gasche fotografie
mit dieser bilder mit dieser wenigen
bilder
sie hatten bauern fotografiert eine
bestandaufnahme also diese zeit 30er
jahre gemacht und diese bestandsaufnahme
zeigt eine realität die nicht zu
verleugnen ist dass es armut
wir sind jetzt in der geschichte
nochmals zurückgegangen weil wir bei der
rolle ihres vaters waren und meine frage
war die zensur war er letztlich teil
dieses ganzen kommunistischen
diktatorischen systems auch dann ihr
buch ende eines familienromans sie
werden von journalisten zum
schriftsteller kann nicht erscheinen
während jahren wegen der zensur von was
haben sie überhaupt gelebt in diesen
jahren
ja das ist eine große frage aber das ist
eine eigentliche sehr schöne geschichte
ich habe meine stelle nach dem einmarsch
der warschauer pakt staaten in die
tschechoslowakei aufgegeben ich wollte
nicht mehr
journalistisch arbeiten konnte ich hätte
dass es war unmöglich unmöglich also ich
blieb in diesem dorf wo ich gerade war
ich war bei meinen freunden und
dann habe ich ein zimmer gemietet dann
später in andere also ich war
untermieter sozusagen untermieter beiden
alten ordensfrau und für 300 forint 300
forint war mir sehr viel
und das hat wirklich schwierigkeit
gemacht ich habe auch nicht viel zu
essen gehabt ich habe auch eine kleine
katze eine katze gehabt und die alte
bauern frauen haben entdeckt dass ich
nicht viel esse sie haben keine fragen
gestellt und dann ihre eigene
erzeugnisse gebracht und sie haben wir
sagt das zu viel ist ob ich nicht abel
nema und natürlich nahm ich ab und dann
war das eine gang und gäbe geworden sie
haben alles möglich er mir gegeben also
ernst boden und und alle möglichen und
dann dann habe ich mich damit auf den
also das schwierigste geschaffen
dann habe ich schwarz arbeiten gehabt
geistiges schwarz arbeiten wo sie doch
etwas geld verdienen konnten ja ja und
mein main miete bezahlen konnte und
elektrizität und so etwas bezahlen
konnte und dann habe ich für diese alte
bauern frau verbrannt wunderbare
arbeiten was ich ansonsten hätte nicht
kennengelernt
ich habe eine ahnung schon aus meinen
kindheit gehabt über gärtnerei oder
gartenarbeit
in diesem maße habe ich in diesem dorf
beim journal
alles das gelernt also das war
eigentlich eine schöne zeit eine schwere
zeit habe eine schöne zeit weil das war
freiheit ganz einfach das war in der
landschaft in einem donauinsel das
verstören und ich war frei sie leben ja
heute auch in einem kleinen dorf an der
slowenischen grenze in süd west ungarn
und auch in budapest teilweise was ist
ihnen das geblieben das ländliche gehen
wir mal zu ihrem neuesten die in
deutscher sprache jedenfalls übersetzten
großen werk parallel geschichten das
hätte nämlich mit dem jahr 1989 also mit
dieser großen öffnung an dieser roman
hat über 1700 seiten in der deutschen
übersetzung von christina wir die bibel
das war ja der titel ihrer ersten
erzählung die bibel hat in natura 1400
seiten also sie haben noch die bibel
übertroffen das ist ein opus magnum in
dem es um die europäische geschichte
geht ich sage jetzt mal aus der sicht
einer deutschen und einer ungarischen
familie
es sind sehr viele parallele gestalten
dass hier durch diesen roman bewegen
dieses zwanzigste jahrhundert dass sie
da revue passieren lassen mit vielen
ereignissen die mich jetzt an ihre
persönlichen geschichten die sie jetzt
erzählt haben erinnern im weitesten sinn
des wortes
all diese tragischen geschichten dann
aber auch all die tragisch komischen
geschichten auch lustige geschichten was
ist das für ein europa das fahrzeug
bleibt nach ihrem roman
parallelgeschichte
europa der versehrten versehrten von
verschiedenen kriegen verschiedener
ideologien die die große menschenmassen
in die wüste geführt haben versehrten
der von kolonialkriege die wir
eigentlich nicht richtig sehen oder
nicht richtig treffen aber die folgen
schon und ja so etwas also mehr trauer
niedergeschlagenheit als hoffnung
nein das würde ich nicht sagen das würde
ich nicht sagen die europäische kultur
ist eine starke kultur stark auch in der
reflexion und das ist eine sehr wichtige
punkt und ich bin ein reflektierter
mensch vielleicht über reflektiert das
ist auch ein gefahr aber ohne reflexion
kommen wir nicht aus und alle nationen
die mit ihrer geschichte ohne reflexion
auskennen auskommen möchten sind auf
scheitern verurteilt und alle die das
nicht machen sind auf nicht scheitern
verurteilt also hier kann man auch
maßhalten marcel erinnern dass es sehr
wichtig vergessen ist auch wichtig nicht
weniger wichtig als erinnern und auch
hier ein maßhalten und ich mache in
diesem roman nichts anderes als an
gewissen vorgänger reflektiere am
vorgänger
wo wir ohne reflexion nicht mehr
rauskommen gerade gefahren werden
beleuchtet und das gehört zu meinem
beruf dass es hängt nicht mit optimismus
oder pessimismus mit hoffnung und
hoffnungslosigkeit zusammen das gehört
zu meinem beruf auch einem arzt wird man
nicht sagen dass er gewisse dinge nicht
in betracht zieht dann ist der ein
schlechter atem
ich habs jetzt vielleicht so als
historischen roman geschildert es ist
natürlich auch ein roman unglaublicher
figuren müssen unglaublich lebendige
roman der eben auch diesen sog des
erzählens entwickelt es ein roman in dem
die leiber die körper ganz konkret eine
große rolle spielen indem die sexualität
einen großen platz ab und das treibt
mich schon um da gibt es eine beischlaf
szene während mehreren tagen und nächten
dies ich weiß nicht über 80 oder 100
seiten geschildert warum müssen wir das
so genau wissen
ich habe das also das ist eine
kurzfassung ich hätte das plus fast
länger spielen können das ist eine
kurzfassung na ja man hätte das also
nicht unbedingt hätte man das schreiben
so warum sollte man das schreiben warum
sollte man darüber nicht schweigen weil
zwischen klinik und pornografie wünschen
wir uns eine richtige reflexion fläche
und dazu ist literatur da um zu
verhindern dass man ihn die pornografie
oder in die klinische sprache wo alles
alle vorgänge lateinische namen
und sterilisiert sind und wir sind nicht
steril als menschen ihr sind nicht das
tut mir leid wir sehen so aus wir
bemühen uns so auszusehen
und das ist auch wichtig weil wenn es
nicht so wäre dann wäre chaos
ausgebrochen und wir sind gegen den
chaos aber in uns ist chaos und das muss
geschichtet werden irgendwo irgendwann
für gewisse leute in einem kleinen kreis
aber nicht in privat kreisen an das ist
auch verboten hast du das kunst oder
literatur ist dafür da ja ich habe mich
einfach gefragt ob das so eine art
ventil funktion auch ist in so
druckqualität zeiten oder system das
sich das dann auf den körper reduziert
aber sie schildern sie jetzt mehr es ist
teil des lebens ja dass das ist also
vielleicht hat die frage so ergeben weil
ich diese arbeiten buch der erinnerung
und parallel geschichten in der diktatur
schrieb parallel geschichten habe ich in
der diktatur angefangen zu schreiben und
dann später aus mehreren gründen weiter
geschrieben aber in der diktatur stellte
sich die frage ob ich in der liebe in
einer beziehung in dem bett frei bin
oder nicht und ich habe buch der
erinnerung angefangen wie wie ein
wissenschaftler dass thesen aufstellt
und die thesen dann beweist oder
verneint und wegwirft und die these war
dass man in der diktatur in der liebe
frei ist und während des schreibens bin
ich darauf gekommen dass man in der
liebe genau so unfrei ist wie
wie in der politik unser bei warner oder
in der gemeinde und das war eine
ziemlich ziemlich ernüchternde
erkenntnis und diese ernüchternde
erkenntnis hat mich dann weitergeführt
sozusagen um zu prüfen ob ihn der
bürgerliche gesellschaft in der
demokratie in der umstände oder in der
verhältnissen der politischen freiheit
der mensch in dem bett in der liebe in
seiner intimsten beziehungen frei bewegt
oder nicht und wahrscheinlich nicht
sondern ist befangen
diese 120 seiten ungefähr diese liebe
liebe szene ist dazu da zu untersuchen
warum die beiden einander nicht finden
obwohl sie eine liebes vergnügen
ohnegleichen erleben sie finden einander
nicht weil alles soziale kräfte die alle
erlebnisse die das nicht zulassen
denn das nicht zulassen und dass es
nicht so selten im leben das man nicht
genau weiß mit wem man spricht und
deswegen gibt man das sprechen auf und
gibt sich an tastsinn und spürsinn und
dann erfährt man etwas was wiederum
nicht auf worte wieder übersetzt werden
kann dann entstehen wiederum daraus neue
konflikte um dann scheitert diese
beziehung unter scheitert nicht aber
jedenfalls wird dadurch schwierig also
das ist
schlachtfeld bett ist keine kleine ort
der freiheit das ist ein fehler daran zu
denken das ist ein sehr wichtiger ort
aber man muss ganz genau wissen was
woher kommt das machen sie genau hin
auch bei der homosexualität und da bin
ich gefragt die nicht auch einen großen
stellenwert einen parallel geschichten
habe mich gefragt ist das weil gerade
die homosexualität über jahrhunderte
verteufelt wird an den rand gedrängt
wird in der antike ist das nicht
verteufelt sondern gerade gefördert und
in der antike schriften sprechen
spricht man darüber ganz anders nein
nein ich habe das aus not gemacht und
diese not war mir sehr wichtig weil weil
die liebesromane haben meinte sozusagen
kaputt gemacht
also ich konnte etwas in der
gleichgeschlechtlicher liebe ich spreche
nicht gerne über homosexualität und
heterosexualität man hat nur einer und
das ist erotik und er wurde gestern
götter verbunden also mit dingen die
nicht fassbar sind und geschlecht ist
selbst ein ding was nicht fassbar ist
obwohl geschlechtsteile fassbar sein
oder sind aber wir wir gehen etwas nach
was sie mal ist und unfassbare ist liebe
und das bekommen wir nicht durch
geschlechtsteilen sondern auch das ist
auch vielleicht ein
ein moment also all das musste musste
ich untersuchen und bei der
gleichgeschlechtlichen liebe war dass
das weinen bessere experimentierfeld
einerseits andererseits ich habe die
beiden sozusagen parallel laufen lassen
laufen lassen und dann zeige ich auch
die die bd spannungen zwischen diese
felder 18 jahre haben sie gearbeitet an
diesem werk jetzt würden wir meinen wir
sind bei der liebe das war der ganze
peter nádas ist er noch nicht es gibt
eben noch den fotografen und da haben
wir bilder vorbereitet aus den 60er
jahren war es ein beispiel die ärmsten
der armen heißt diese fotografie von
ihnen aus dem jahr 1963 und in dieser
ausstellung im kunsthaus in zug mit den
titel in der dunkelkammer des schreibens
gibt es dann auch dieses zweite bild
viele andere mehr
guck mal was hat die an ist der titel
auch aus den frühen 60er jahren
mir fällt auf auch bei den vielen
fotografien sie haben viele fotografien
auch in dieser ausstellung gebracht und
fotografen aus ungarn sind große namen
wie andré kertesz dabei und so weiter
das einerseits dieses elend und
andererseits diese lebensfreude aus den
bildern heraus spricht kein widerspruch
ist dass beides sozusagen ungarische
spezialität
das ist gleichzeitig da alles ist
gleichzeitig das ist die verschiedensten
dinge sind gleichzeitig da die
gleichzeitigen da ja dass das macht das
leben gerade unglaublich interessant und
aufregend
das alles ist gleichzeitig da auch dann
wenn ich werde nicht im elende bieten
dann ist auch gleichzeitig freude da
nicht meiner
aber das ist da also mich reizt die
parallelität und meine vorgänger in der
ungarische fotografie waren ganz ähnlich
es ging es ganz ähnlich die gigantische
fotografie ist aus der schrecknissen der
ersten weltkrieges ausgegangen es gab
hofmaler und hoffotografen im krieg gab
es kriegs maler und kriegsfotografen
stellte zwei große kriegsfotografen aus
barock und luftballon und andré kertész
alle beiden haben das schrecken gelernt
mit dem adeya gehängte schützen genia
und tote und auch die latrine und auch
dass sie diesen soldaten mehrere
nebeneinander auf der latrine winkels
ist günstiges form von kertész
fotografiert oder die die die
unglaubliche schutzlosigkeit dieser
männer die hinein badewanne zusammen
baden und einander mit zwei vereinen
haben wahrscheinlich offiziere die
irgendwo ein badewanne gefunden habe ihn
ohne die ohne toilette und diddy diddy
aber der
dienst junge steht da neben diese
badewanne also alle diese
gebrechlichkeit diese kleine freunde
keine freude freuden sind ab jetzt
dieses bild die ärmsten der armen
diese fotografie hätten sie nicht
verkaufen können weil das ungeschminkte
realität zeigt oder ja das ist nicht für
eine zeitung dass man nicht für eine
zeitung ich war als zeitungsreporter
hingegangen mit einer journalist
zusammen und wir haben diese familie
besucht aus irgendwelchen grund was ich
jetzt nicht erzähle aber nö
das war das hing zusammen damit zusammen
dass von dieser alte frau sein kleines
besitz weggenommen wurde und
kollektiviert wurde und das kind hat
gestern ein schub bekommen
diese show ist auf diesen deal nicht
richtig zu singen und die waren wirklich
bettler geworden noch erleben wie früher
und ich konnte das bild nicht macht
nicht nicht machen
also ich musste das bild natürlich
verkaufen oder die zeitung geben konnte
ich das nicht weil der komischerweise
wurde oder gezwungenermaßen war noch die
bilder also das war ein bilderverbot nur
bilder durchgegangen sind die
fröhlichkeit optimismus ausstrahlt
deswegen stützend ja dass wir uns
scheitert es
ich als fotograf zwei neuere bilder aus
den 2000 also vorbei jahren gemacht
selbstbildnis mit selbstbildnis aus dem
jahr 2001 und in der schreibstube ein
bild aus dem jahr 2000 polarität fällt
schon auf es gibt noch viele deren mehr
die sich im inneren von räumen abspielen
ist es so eine art wenn sie jetzt nicht
mehr fotografieren habe jedoch noch
fotograf geblieben sind eine art rückzug
nein das ergibt sich aus mehreren
mehrere quellen einerseits bin ich in
meinem kindheit sehr nahezu zu maler
gewesen und man entweder stillleben oder
landschaften oder interviews also
interview fotografie war mir immer sehr
wichtig man stellt seine eigene
interieur da oder stellt ein an andere
fremde interview
da und das ist immer sehr stark vom
licht abhängig welche art oder welche
menge vom licht durch das fenster durch
den fenster kommt und wie das dann die
gegenstände abzeichen also die innenwelt
einer persönlichkeit ein innenwelt einer
persönlichkeit und ich habe meine
sozusagen mein lebenslauf sozusagen mit
interviews geschrieben fotografiert ich
habe alle meine schreibtische
fotografiert nicht habe mein leben beim
schreibtischen verbracht ist mir
aufgefallen dass ist ein wechsel gibt
eben von der schwarz-weiß-fotografie zur
farbfotografie ja das ist das ist
eigentlich das ist ein zufall
ja ich habe farbfotografie gelernt aber
nie mit farbe fotografiert ich blieb bei
das schwarz weiß dann habe ich
angefangen den born auf unseren hof zu
fotografieren ich habe ein leben ein
jahr lang da geblieben bei dem bau und
mehrere tausend aufnahmen richten sich
diese ausstellung riesiger baum und und
dann dann durch diese diese zwangen weil
das habe ich mit polaroid gemacht und es
reizte mich diese besondere kolorit was
polaroid macht dann bin ich
gewissermaßen bei dem auch geblieben mit
barlow polaroid und auch unipolare aber
ich habe fotografie sozusagen aufgegeben
helms fotografiere ich nicht mehr
die analoge fotografie war mein terrain
und digitale fotografie ist für die
leute da
das muss noch erfunden werden also da
gibt es auch zeit bei einem zeitpunkt wo
sie gemerkt haben dass sie sehr
geschlossen für mich ja analoge
fotografie ist eine abgeschlossene
kapitel es gibt fotografen die das
weiterführen so weiter machen aber das
ist sehr umständlich geworden also man
ist an verschiedene analoge fotografie
hat eine art materialität material
gebunden
um diese materialität oder material
gebundenheit musste aufgegeben werden
und ich habe keine zeit und keine
möglichkeit mich um darum zu kümmern
ja ich erinnere mich an diese fotolabors
wo man die bilder noch natürlich in die
flüssigkeit geht und ja also alle
chemikalien sind sind kompliziert zu
beschaffen und man kann natürlich alles
selbst machen ich habe auch gelernt dass
selbst zu machen
ich hatte eine andere vermutung nach
wegen dem umstieg von herr schwarz weiß
auf die farbfotografie sie haben 1993
ein herzinfarkt knapp überlebt und es
scheint mir so um diese zeit verbund
nach mit einem nahtoderlebnis gibt es
dann nachher mehr farbe in ihrem leben
könnt ihr das sei eigentlich schon
eigentlich schon weil danach habe ich
angefangen diesen baum zu fotografieren
sei diese einsame baum der eigentlich
länger lebt viel länger lebt als ein
mensch und ich habe diese bedürfnisse
dürfe nichts nach nach meinen eigenen
klinischen tod zu beobachten wie ein
lebewesen und das ist enorm ist auch ein
lebewesen wie ein lebewesen das schafft
so lange zu leben
und dann habe ich mit dem resultat dass
diese experiment herausgekommen dass
diese lebewesen in eine andere
zeitrechnung hat und diese zeitrechnung
diese unsere zeitrechnung gar nicht
kennt also kennt auch keine jahreszeiten
kennt auch keine tage
das kind kennt erkennt licht das ist
eine verbindende moment mit der mensch
auch für uns ist licht kulturell ist
licht sehr wichtige steht auf der
höchste stelle der kultur schlicht haben
sie bei diesem nahtod erlebnis wird ja
mama so erzählt ihr leben noch mal wie
in einem film gesehen nein nein nein das
ist auch ein metapher was der
zurückgeholte so versuchten ihre
erlebnisse das ist er hat die ganze
vermögen des gehirns gleichzeitig da
wäre weil die zeit ist auf obst
ausgesetzt
und ich spüre nichts also mein spürsinn
ist weg spüre nichts ich erfahre von der
gegenwärtigen nichts
und dadurch ist diese große tor große
speicher eröffnet und ich erlebe
gleichzeitig alles ich kann alles wie
beim computer alles abrufen aber alles
abrufbare ist gleichzeitig er hat keine
zeit mehr oder hat keine begrenzung mehr
und deswegen ist selbst diese situation
oder wann das ist kein erleben ist
sondern eine eine andere dimension aber
gut nennen wir das situation dieser
situation deswegen ist mit den
unendlichkeit gleich
fahre erst mal in meinem leben was
unwilligkeit ist das gleichzeitig mit
dem geburt identisch ist in der
erinnerung
also was religion und mythologien sagen
dass das die beiden tod und geburt 1 ist
das ist das wird war also alles wonach
wir streben unendlichkeit stadt ständige
endlichkeit geborgenheit ist da haben
sie danach ihr leben geändert
nein nicht richtig aber eine menge hat
sich zuvor selbst gehandelt ich habe
keinen anlass gesehen mein leben zu
ändern
ich habe aufgehört zu rauchen
das ist eine änderung aber außer dem
nichts aber eine menge hat sich geändert
in gewissen dingen bin ich sicherer
geworden und bescheiden viel
bescheidener also aber das ändert ändert
er sich schon von sich selbst dann habe
ich keine todesangst mehr obwohl ich
weiß dass physisch also mein körper ob
ich es will oder nicht will hat diese
angst weil körper wählt immer und in
jeder situation über leben wollen klar
obwohl ich das gutheißen oder nichts
er will das immer kertesz sagt in seiner
rede zum nobelpreis ihr großer
schriftsteller kollege also ungarn im
jahr 2002 ganz am ende
das heißt über auschwitz nachdenken
denke ich paradoxerweise vielleicht eher
über die zukunft nach als über die
vergangenheit hin dass für sie ja ja
also ich halte alle philosophien und
alle technologien und das ist sehr
wichtig für null und nichtig die nach
auschwitz über auschwitz nicht
nachdenken also über den gott oder über
alles andere kann ich ohne auschwitz
nicht mehr denken muss das verstehen und
muss nachgehen was war das es gibt der
eigene strömungen wie zum beispiel eine
theologie nachricht dass die sich dann
ja ein programm gemacht aber das ist
wenig weil dass es kein programm punkt
sondern muss jeder in die kirche geht
und über die vorsorge oder irgend etwas
nachdenkt über drüber nachdenkt muss
nachgehen was ist ein mensch der fähig
ist er dulden oder mitzumachen
ohne diese art von denken geht das
wirklich nicht weiter oder geht in eine
andere sackgasse wieder an
darüber reflektieren sie in ihrem werk
in hohem maße seit jahren wird das ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses sehr offene
gespräche
ich danke
[Musik]
das gespräch mit peter nádas finden sie
auf unserer website sie können es aber
auch als dvd kaufen dazu schreiben sie
wie immer an schweizer radio und
fernsehen redaktion sternstunden 80 52
zürich ihre e mail erreichte uns unser
stern kopien srf punkt ch diese woche
ist bekannt geworden dass peter nádas
sein fotografisches werk dem kunsthaus
zug schenkt noch bis nächsten sonntag
können sie dort fotos von peter nádas 10
und zwar in einer ausstellung unter dem
schönen titel in der dunkelkammer des
schreibens in einer woche geht es in der
sternstunde philosophie um selbst
gebasteltes selber machen nämlich ist im
trend ob bier oder geburtsanzeige aber
ist selber machen wegweisend oder nur
sinnlose ressourcenverschwendung dazu
ein streitgespräch nächsten sonntag
jetzt aber geht es zurück in die 60er
jahre sein cover zur beatles platte
revolver war stilprägend und holte sich
einen grammy
ein film über klaus fuhrmann bassist
grafiker und enger freund der beatles